in many videos we have already talked
about electron configuration and now in
this video we're going to extend that
understanding by thinking about the
electron configuration of ions so these
are going to be charged atoms so let's
just start looking at some examples
let's say we are dealing with fluorine
now we know what a neutral fluorine
atoms electron configuration would be in
fact if you want a little bit of
practice try to pause this video and
think about what is the electron
configuration of a neutral fluorine atom
all right now let's work through this
together a neutral fluorine atom has
nine electrons and we could just use our
periodic table of elements so first
we're going to have two electrons in 1s
so we'll have one s two and then we're
going to go to the second shell so then
we go to two s two so so far we have
filled in four electrons and next we go
to the 2p sub-shell and we are going to
have if we're talking about a neutral
fluorine we are going to have one two
three four five electrons in that 2p
subshell
so it's 2p five so if that's the
electron configuration for fluorine what
do you think the electron configuration
for fluoride would be so this is just
the anion that has one extra electron it
is a negatively charged ion pause this
video and try to figure it out well here
you're now going to have one extra
electron the fluorine has nabbed an
electron from someplace and so where
will that extra electron go
well our 2p sub-shell has space for one
more electron so that's where it will go
so the fluoride anion is going to have
an electron configuration of 1 s 2 2 s 2
2 P and that's going to have an Electra
electron here 2p 6
2p 6 now let's do another example let's
say we wanted to figure out the electron
configuration of a part positively
charged calcium ion
so calcium let's make it 2 plus so
that's a positive charge of 2 so this is
you could view this as a neutral calcium
that has lost two electrons what would
be its electron configuration pause this
video and try to figure that out all
right well one way to figure this out is
first we could figure out the electron
configuration of a neutral neutral
calcium neut neutral calcium atom and
then from that we can take two of the
highest energy electrons away and so
neutral calcium you could view it
actually let's do it in noble gas
configuration neutral calcium the noble
gas that comes right before calcium is
argon so it's going to have the electron
configuration of argon and then we are
going to have two electrons for that
fourth shell that's going to fill in the
four s subshell and so we're going to
have argon and then we're going to have
let me do this in a new color let's call
this for s2 now what do you think is
going to happen if we were to lose two
electrons well those two electrons in
that four s subshell and that fourth
shell are going to go away and so the
electron configuration here for calcium
with a positive two charge this calcium
cation is going to be the electron
configuration of argon and no 4s to so
it's actually going to have the exact
same electron configuration as argon so
I will leave you there just a couple of
examples and I encourage you if you're
feeling if you're in the mood just pick
any of these atoms any of these elements
and think about what would happen if
they gained or lost an electron and what
their electron configurations might be